bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 21 avril le premier mois de guerre
au kosovo s'achève mais les
bombardements des avions de l'otan
continuent de façon intensive une cible
symbolique était touché à belgrade le
siège du parti socialiste de slobodan
milosevic la détermination de
l'engagement de la france ne change pas
à 20h messieurs jacques chirac
s'exprimera de nouveau les réfugiés de
macédoine et d'albanie sont en situation
d'extrême urgence l'otan refusent de
fournir des informations sur les
personnes déplacées à l'intérieur du
kosovo nous serons en albanie et les
canetons signer et au monténégro en
direct avec maryse burgot puis nous
ferons le bilan ce premier mois de
guerre bilan des discours et des actes
des affirmations et des propagandes
l'actualité c'est aussi aux états unis
près de denver dans le colorado la folie
meurtrière encore inexpliquée de deux
adolescents qui ont tué 15 personnes
dans un lycée enquête sur les armes et
la violence aux états unis monsieur
nicolas sarkozy fera équipe avec
monsieur alain madelin pour conduire la
liste rpr démocratie libérale aux
élections européennes nous évoquerons
les programmes respectifs de l'udf et du
rpr et puis in avec monsieur nicolas
sarkozy nous entretiendrons il sera
notre invité en direct dans quelques
instants
enfin le sport du football l'olympique
de marseille en finale de la coupe
d'europe affrontera parme à moscou le 12
mai prochain et hier soir in extremis
laurent blanc a qualifié son équipe
c'est être à bologne pour cette nouvelle
journée de frappes de l'aviation des
pays membres de l'otan une trentaine
d'objectifs ont été attaqués mais le
plus symbolique d'entre eux et le siège
du parti socialiste serbes de slobodan
milosevic situé en plein centre de
belgrade commentaires françois korber
3h15 la nuit dernière à belgrade 2
ici il a simultanément ratent leur cible
dix secondes plus tard un troisième
missile touche l'immeuble qui abrite le
siège du parti socialiste au pouvoir de
slobodan milosevic une cible hautement
symbolique signifiant d'après l'otan
qu'il n'existait pas de sanctuaire pour
le président yougoslave
outre le siège du sps le gratte-ciel de
23 étages abritait aussi la
radiotélévision cochard a dirigé par
maria milosevic
la fille du leader yougoslave mais
également la chaîne de télévision ping
propriété d'un membre du parti de la
gauche unie parti dirigé par mira
markovic les pousses de slobodan
milosevic au delà toutefois de ce qui
apparaît comme une phrase symbolique ce
raid pourrait avoir un autre objectif
selon des sources proches de l'alliance
un centre de renseignement militaire
yougoslave et un centre de communication
opérée dans cet immeuble entièrement
dévastée par un gigantesque incendie que
les pompiers mettront des heures à
éteindre
d'après belgrade quinze personnes se
trouvaient à l'intérieur au moment de
cette frappe par les missiles dans les
carcasses ont été retrouvés au petit
jour au pied du bâtiment une trentaine
d'objectifs on est effectivement inquiet
lundi dernier en yougoslavie dont le
dernier des trois ponts de novi sad en
voïvodine qui enjambait le danube ce
pont stratégique pour le mouvement des
forces yougoslaves reliait la deuxième
ville de serbie à la rive droite du
fleuve au 28e jour de l'opération forces
alliées l'otan accentue sa pression sur
le pouvoir use au stade avec d'autres
bombardements à valjevo contre des
suicides civil travaillant pour
l'industrie d'armement
cet après-midi les 24 hélicoptères de
combat anti char américain apache qui
devraient être engagés à partir de la
semaine prochaine au kosovo contre les
forces serbes sont arrivés aujourd'hui
sur l'aéroport de tirana en albanie
l'engagement de ses apache n'est pas un
premier pas vers une guerre thérèse a
souligné un officier de l'otan mais un
substitut à l'engagement au sol
les ambassadeurs permanents des 15 pays
membres de l'union européenne viennent
de se mettre d'accord pour interdire la
vente et la fourniture de pétrole à la
république fédérale de yougoslavie
l'accord doit maintenant être confirmée
lundi prochain par les ministres
européens des affaires étrangères
pour la quatrième fois depuis le début
de l'action de temps le président
jacques chirac va s'exprimer dans
quelques instants il a réuni cet après
midi un conseil restreint auquel
participait le premier ministre lionel
jospin plusieurs membres du gouvernement
ainsi que des militaires demain monsieur
chirac doit rejoindre washington pour
participer au sommet de l'otan à
l'occasion du 50e anniversaire de cette
occasion il souhaite donc faire le point
de la situation au kosovo de
l'engagement la france et expliquer les
positions qui défendra demain à
washington
monsieur chirac mes chers compatriotes
la semaine dernière les quinze chefs
d'état et de gouvernement de l'union
européenne se réunissaient à bruxelles
ils ont pris à l'unanimité une position
commune sur la crise du kosovo
approbation de l'action engagée par
l'otan détermination à conduire cette
action jusqu'à son père recherche d'une
sortie politique de la crise assurant
durablement la stabilité de la région
dans le respect des droits de l'homme et
des règles de la démocratie
après demain ce sont les 19 pays de
l'alliance atlantique
européens et américains qui seraient dus
réuniront à washington et je voudrais
vous dire dans quel esprit
j'aborde ce sommet
quel est notre objectif je le répète
arrêter la répression et obtenir le
retrait des forces serbes du kosovo
assurer le retour des réfugiés trouver
les voies d'un accord politique
permettant la reconstruction de la
province et comprenant une garantie
internationale de sécurité pour tous ses
habitants et la france bien entendu
participera le moment venu à la mise en
oeuvre de cette force de protection et
de paix pour atteindre cet objectif nous
avons choisi vous le savez d'exercer une
pression croissante sur les forces
serbes
en utilisant les frappes aériennes parce
qu'elles sont les plus précises et
qu'elle limite les risques pour les
populations
aujourd'hui nous avons réduit fortement
la mobilité des forces serbes
nous les empêchons de se concentrer et
nous les coupons progressivement de leur
ravitaillement et de leurs bases et
pourtant le régime de belgrade sans tête
il provoque il poursuit sa terrible
politique d'épuration ethnique à sakhr
viols pillages villages incendiés
familles séparées et jetés sur les
routes
voilà l'action des autorités serbes
voilà ce qui doit cesser nous devons
donc intensifier encore ses frappes
mettre en oeuvre des moyens
supplémentaires et attaquer des
objectifs de plus en plus diversifiées
dont la destruction pèsera de plus en
plus lourdement sur l'action des forces
et sur le fonctionnement
du régime serbe voilà la position que je
prendrais en machine
je proposerai aussi de mieux aider les
pays voisins qui subissent de plein
fouet les effets de ce drame
l'union européenne déjà décidé une aide
économique et humanitaire considérable
au sommet nous rencontrerons les chefs
d'état de ces pays pour examiner dans un
esprit de solidarité leurs problèmes de
sécurité je pense en particulier à la
macédoine et à l'albanie
ces deux pays et le monténégro porte
tout le poids de l'accueil de six cent
mille réfugiés kosovars chassés de leurs
foyers par les forces serbes
l'aide de la communauté internationale
celle des européens pour l'essentiel
leur permet aujourd'hui de mieux faire
face à la poursuite de cet exode de
soulager les souffrances des populations
déportées que nous devons accentuer
notre effort et je veux encore souligné
le rôle exemplaire joué par nos
associations humanitaires
j'ai tenu à les rencontrer à l'elysée
pour voir avec elle et avec le
gouvernement comment l'état est d'abord
nos soldats pouvait leur apporter appui
et assistance sur le terrain et je veux
aussi remercier à nouveau les français
pour leur générosité et en particulier
les familles qui ont proposé
d'accueillir dans leur foyer des
réfugiés kosovars
quant aux populations qui se trouvent
encore au kosovo elles sont en gras
danger et nous cherchons tous les moyens
je dis bien tous les moyens permettant
de les aider je rappelle aux autorités
serbes qu'elles sont responsables de
leur sort et qu'elles devront rendre des
comptes
enfin il est indispensable que l'union
européenne joue tout son rôle dans le
règlement politique d'une crise qui se
déroule à ses portes dans cet esprit
avec le premier ministre j'ai proposé
que l'union européenne se voit confier
par l'onu
lorsque la paix sera rétabli la
responsabilité d'administrer
provisoirement le kosovo cette
proposition qui ouvre une perspective
d'avenir a été adoptée à l'unanimité par
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement lors
du dernier conseil européen
ainsi à l'initiative de notre pays et
pour la première fois
l'union européenne est prête à assumer
ses responsabilités dans le règlement
d'une crise majeure
on a trop reproché à l'europe sa
faiblesse dans ce domaine pour ne pas
saluer cette détermination nouvelle
dans le même esprit je rappellerai à
l'occasion de ce sommet que l'europe
doit mieux exercer ses responsabilités
de défense au sein comme en dehors de
l'alliance deux premiers progrès ont été
enregistrés sur la base de nos
propositions
avec le plein appui de la
grande-bretagne et de l'allemagne
il faut aujourd'hui accélérer le
mouvement
mes chers compatriotes ce que nous
vivons vous le savez c'est
l'affrontement entre la barbarie et la
démocratie c'est un vrai combat pour la
paix et pour les droits de l'homme sur
notre continent
c'est le combat de l'honneur nous devons
le mener jusqu'à son terme et nous
devons le gagner
l'intervention de monsieur jacques
chirac qu on aura noté au début à la fin
de cette intervention le même mode de
détermination détermination
disponibilité diligence sont également
les maux dont a usé monsieur jospin pour
qualifier la politique du gouvernement
et de la france à propos de la crise au
kosovo détermination militaire
disponibilité diplomatique et diligence
humanitaire un résumé qui nous permet ce
soir de tenter de dresser un bilan bilan
d'un premier mois de guerre
marqué par les images terribles de
l'exode de centaines de milliers
d'albanais du kosovo rappel et
commentaires avec richard biner lorsque
le 24 mars le premier b 52 américains
décollent de la base de fer ford en
grande bretagne les objectifs politiques
de l'eau dedans semble clairement
définis il s'agit de faire revenir
slobodan milosevic la table des
négociations après l'échec de
rambouillet et mettre un terme aux
exactions des serbes contre les albanais
du kosovo
les forces de l'alliance dispose d'une
supériorité numérique
400 avions de combat contre 80 pour la
yougoslavie belgrade devraient
rapidement plié
le malien se sont entendus pour
neutraliser les noailles entier aérien
de la serbie la république de
yougoslavie et se sont donné un certain
nombre d'objectifs qui vont être
atteints d'autres jours comme lors de la
guerre du golfe les alliés veulent
s'assurer la maîtrise du ciel aéroport
militaire radars batteries anti
aériennes sont pilonnés mais bien vite
les stratèges de l'otan découvre la
résistance des forces serbes à leur
guerre technologique plusieurs centaines
de sites sont touchés 30 nick a battu ou
détruits au sol
mais après quatre semaines de frappes
les défenses antiaériennes yougoslave ne
sont pas totalement neutralisé notamment
ses rampes de lancement mobile
difficiles à détecter
le temps concentre alors ses attaques
sur des objectifs stratégiques et
économiques raffinerie pont cazères le
poste de commandement le 3 avril huit
missiles atteignent le ministère de
l'intérieur où coeur même de belgrade
notre mission est clair réduire les
capacités de nuisance de l'ennemi et
rendre impossible une attaque encore
plus sanglante contre les civils
innocents du kosovo puis pourquoi dès
les premiers jours du conflit
le temps fait état d'exactions commises
par les serbes au kosovo par centaines
de milliers des réfugiés arrivent dans
les pays limitrophes particulièrement en
macédoine et en albanie
ainsi que les premiers témoignages des
deux hommes était expulsé son village
brûlé
slobodan milosevic utilisent les
déportations massives comme une arme de
guerre
en un mois huit cent mille personnes
quittent le kosovo les forces de l'otan
sont impuissantes à endiguer cet afflux
massif et montana d'une vaste opération
humanitaire abris alliés l'action menée
par milosevic ne triomphera pas la
barbarie ne peut avoir le dernier mot
la justice doit passer et les criminels
devront rendre des comptes
désormais les institutions serbes seront
la cible des forces alliées en début de
semaine wesley clark commandant suprême
des portes de l'otan en europe assuré
que l'alliance allait détruire tout ce à
quoi le président yougoslave tenait le
siège du gouvernement de voïvodine a été
bombardé et la nuit dernière l'otan
frappe est même le siège du sps le
propre parti de mélodies beach d'ici la
fin avril la flotte aérienne engagée
aura presque doublé atteignant 1000
appareils tandis qu'au sol
les troupes déployées à des titres
divers réuniront bientôt trente mille
hommes faisant de la macédoine et de
l'albanie des bases arrières de l'otan
qui pourrait un jour venir servir à une
intervention terrestre
alors donc le conflit entre dans sa
cinquième semaine et que des frappes
aériennes atteignent systématiquement
les infrastructures de communication
servi voici rapportés par notre envoyé
spécial à belgrade qui travaillent dans
les conditions de contrôle
jacques merino ce qui se dit ce qui
s'entend parmi la population serbe sous
les bombardements
au premier regard la vie à belgrade 2
semble tout à fait normal malgré ce mois
de bombardements il y à de l'électricité
il y à de l'eau courante les ascenseurs
fonctionnent le feux rouges fonctionnent
les magasins sont normalement
approvisionnées on mange tout à fait à
sa fin et on ne manque de rien les
cinémas et les théâtres sont aussi
également ouvert et contrairement à ce
que personnellement je m'attendais à
découvrir à belgrade
ce n'est pas du tout une ville en état
de siège il n'y a pas de barrage de
police et une présence forte de l'armée
en vérité on voit très peu de policiers
extrêmement peu de militaires le seul le
rationnement qui est instaurée ici est
un rationnement qui concerne l'essence
rationnement relativement léger puisque
qu il le représente 40 litres d'essence
par mois et par personne
mais derrière la fausse nonchalance
affichée par les belgradois qui semble
se vouloir donner l'image d'être
indifférents à cette pression il ya bien
sûr une usure psychologique qui est
extrêmement forte
les chaînes que l'on voyait au début de
ce conflit sur les ponts sont maintenant
beaucoup plus rare en venant dans ce
studio je suis pas
sur le pont où se réunissent les gens il
n'y avait plus qu'une centaine de
personnes de la même manière les
concerts de rock l'après midi au coeur
de belgrade ne rassemble plus que
quelques centaines de personnes
il faut reconnaître que la stratégie de
l'otan ces bombardements réguliers qui
arrivent comme cela chaque jour en fin
de journée ou dans la nuit
exerce un stress psychologique
épouvantable pour la population et ici
tout le monde est à bout de nerfs est
tout à fait luz et le témoignage de
jacques merino donc à belgrade
actuellement selon madame ogata haut
commissaire de l'onu aux réfugiés
l'otan refusent de transmettre les
informations sur les albanais déplacées
à l'intérieur du kosovo
ils seraient des dizaines de milliers
peut-être beaucoup plus en macédoine
plusieurs villages dans celui de milana
dans le nord sont envahis par des
kosovars arrivé depuis quatre jours sans
nourriture sans protection contre les
intempéries
il faut d'urgence accéléré les départs
de ces régions frontalières commentaires
nathalie oiseaux les visages sont
résignés ils ont vu partir les autres
aujourd'hui c'est leur tour de prendre
la route
l'inéluctable hémorragie qui vident
pristina de ses habitants se poursuit
ces images filmées par la télévision
grecque
à l'intérieur même du kosovo hier en
témoigne et lorsque l'équipe grecque de
monde aux réfugiés pourquoi ils fuient
ils répondent de la police serbe les a
obligés à partir toujours les mêmes
routes au nord du kosovo près de
podujevo d'autres images mais cette fois
tourné par la télévision serré et le
récit qui les accompagnent et bien
différent là nous explique-t-on ce sont
les bombardements de l'otan qui chasse
les kosovars de chez eux des questions
bien orienté permettent aux réfugiés de
corroborer la version officielle serbe
quel message peut-on faire passer à ces
criminels qui nous bombarde
qu'ils cessent de lancer des bombes les
serbes décidé à montrer qu'ils font tout
pour aider les réfugiés à rentrer chez
eux
et pourtant cette nuit encore 3000
kosovars se sont réfugiés en macédoine
lorsque les autorités de ce pays les
empêchent d'entrer dans les camps saturé
les voilà qui installent des abris de
fortune comme ici à loyat nik tou tour
qui on a laissé tout et maintenant on
n'a plus rien du tout on a des balades
en classique on a rien à manger les
enfants et sont malades
le mairie sont malades j'ai même failli
me casser cameron lui même fan capita
mans face à une telle urgence et après
quelques pressions occidentales
la macédoine est revenu sur ses
positions elle a finalement autorisé la
construction de nouveaux camps près de
tetovo en albanie à coup que chez les
premières évacuations vers le sud du
pays doivent avoir lieu par hélicoptère
cette opération est réservée en priorité
aux personnes les plus vulnérables voyez
le reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux à
nos consignes et philippe jasmin les
camions sont allés chercher les réfugiés
dans un de ces camps qui entourent kukes
celui ci est un champion
le choix s'est porté sur les familles
vulnérables mère enfant ou sur les
personnes isolées
le hcr a insisté pour que les gosses ne
soit pas séparé soit nous on sait pas
nous a dit qu'il fallait aller à bührer
enfin c'est leur elle est située au
centre de l'albanie à 80 km de coupe
caisse les cinq heures de route familia
la famille et santé du kosovo par la
macédoine mois par l'albanie alors
brunel c'est bien ça me rapproche
on nous a offert d'avoir recours à ces
hélicoptères de l'otan il y avait 200
places on les a proposés à ceux qui
voulaient ils sont en fait 126 réfugiés
mais la météo perturbent les rotations
on a commencé à lui on a fait un peu
pressés à 13 heures maintenant on
recommence encore une fois et avec un
peu de chance on les verra les et
bientôt quelques heures plus tard deux
chimique néerlandais se pose en fait le
plus important de cette opération qui
commençait ce qui ne se voit pas les
hélicoptères de l'otan doivent monter à
kukes de quoi construire une base
logistique pour soutenir le commissariat
aux réfugiés
il va y avoir une base logistique ici on
va installer des grands entrepôts qui
vont garder par les hommes de l'otan ce
qui est très très nécessaire dans ce
genre de région et donc ça va nous
faciliter une grande partie de notre
travail au niveau logistique
les hélicoptères qui achemineront le
matériel pourront redescendre des
réfugiés à ce stade il s'agit d'une
opération de visibilité de l'otan une
opération pilote le véritable moyen pour
les réfugiés de quitter kukes reste le
bus 6000 d'entre eux ont quitté la ville
fière de cette manière
soixante dix personnes sont finalement
partis à 18h10 ce soir la décision de
poursuivre l'opération n'est pas encore
plus en macédoine le président la
république monsieur gligorov souhaite la
proclamation du danger de guerre
imminent en raison des tensions
croissantes dans son pays
l'afflux de plus de 100 120 mille
réfugiés est une menace de
déstabilisation pour la macédoine au
monténégro le président de la république
monsieur djukanovic ne veut pas céder
sur le point de laisser l'armée de stop
the music prendre le contrôle de la
police du monténégro c'est un nouvel
épisode de latence
ou qui règne actuellement dans ce pays
reportage maryse burgot et gilles
jacquier des hélicoptères de l'armée
fédérale yougoslave au dessus de
podgorica des réservistes dans le centre
ville des camions de transport de
troupes ou de matériel les militaires
fidèles à ce logo dames les élites sont
aujourd'hui présents sur toute la
république du monténégro
face à eux une autre force la police
monténégrine fidèles à l'actuel
président pro occidental
milo djukanovic il contrôle d'ici la
frontière entre le monténégro et le
kosovo deux forces en présence et deux
drapeaux l'un et yougoslaves l'autre
monténégrins blague au tamis tritsch et
président de la cour constitutionnelle
du monténégro selon lui le bras de fer
auquel se livre aujourd'hui c'est deux
forces pourrait mener la république vers
la guerre civile
je m
je crois qu'un éventuel conflit entre
l'armée et la police monténégrine est un
objectif politique
je venais de milosevic essaye d'utiliser
la situation d' état de guerre pour
opposer ces deux forces
dans la rue la population est elle aussi
divisée
d'un côté ceux qui soutiennent le
pouvoir actuel de l'autre ceux qui
restent attachés à la fédération
yougoslave dirigé par skoda me lâche cet
homme insulte la france et l'otan lui
bien sûr est dans le camp des pro
milosevic
ce bras de fer entre les uns et les
autres est aujourd'hui à la une de toute
la presse monténégrin du côté du pouvoir
en place
on tient bon mais on s'inquiète beaucoup
l'armée yougoslave son mail si les
forces paramilitaires serbes sans remède
à ce moment là on n'aura absolument
besoin de l'aide de la communauté
européenne et des forces internationales
en attendant le président milo
djukanovic tient tête à slobodan
milosevic
hier soir lors d'une réunion avec le
commandant de la 2e armée yougoslave
il a refusé que sa police soit placée
sous la tutelle des militaires est il
menace aujourd'hui de faire lever par la
force les barrages édifié par l'armée à
l'unique poste frontière entre le
monténégro et le kosovo
et puis maryse burgot demain peuple
korytza vous vous trouvez au monténégro
il y aura une manifestation des
partisans de skoda minos riche donc un
regain de tensions possibles
oui cette manifestation devrait
commencer en fait demain soir vers 18
heures elle ne rassemblera effectivement
que les partisans du leader serbe
slobodan milosevic
les organisateurs de cette manifestation
font savoir qu'ils fêteront à leur
manière le 50e anniversaire de la
création de l'otan le pouvoir actuel a
longtemps hésité à interdire cette
manifestation finalement milo djukanovic
milo djukanovic a décidé de laisser
faire
malgré cela ce soir le parlement dit
nous serons très vigilants nous tel ou
tolérons une manifestation contre l'otan
mais nous ne tolérerons pas que cette
que ce rassemblement soit utilisé pour
déstabiliser notre république
le gouvernement veut bien montrer là
qu'il ne se laisse pas impressionner
qu'il ne se laissera pas impressionner
même si demain cette manifestation est
très importante
merci maryse parmi les réactions
enregistrées à l'étranger celle de
monsieur gorbatchev l'ancien président
de l'ex urss accusent l'otan dit
responsabilité dans la crise du kosovo
pour le chef du gouvernement italien
monsieur d'alema bill clinton n'a peut
être pas vu tous les pièges d'une
intervention
et puis en allemagne les divisions au
sein du gouvernement social démocrate
verts à propos de l'intervention de
l'otan que ce veau menace la cohésion de
l'équipe de gerhard schröder
correspondance olivier lerner avec
morgane dombrowski c'est jurgen très
tine qui met encore le feu aux poudres
ministre verte de l'environnement le
khmer vert comme on le surnomme ici pour
ces attitudes parfois cassante à
l'emporter iosca fischer vice chancelier
ministre vert des affaires étrangères a
bien du mal à mettre au pas les membres
de son parti
des pacifistes de base jusqu'aux
ministres les états d'âme s'étalent au
grand jour des rêveurs n'ont jamais fait
bon ménage
je ne suis pas démissionnaires vous
voyez chez c'est toujours en fonction
mais c'est vrai on se pose des questions
c'est cette guerre qu'il faut arrêter
certains verts ont signé des pétitions
pour appeler à la fin de la guerre
d'autres ont demandé à l'otan un
cessez-le-feu unilatéral temporaire des
problèmes de conscience transparaissent
sur ces visages les verts pourraient
donc voté contre les frappes
ils remettent ainsi en question leur
participation au gouvernement du thon
fumé sociaux-démocrates déchirer les
verts c'est l'âme du parti qu'il est
touché et qui risque de faire capoter la
coalition si la guerre au kosovo se
poursuit et conduit l'allemagne à
engager ses troupes au sol le malaise
perceptible aujourd'hui laissera place à
n'en pas douter à une crise ouverte à
une implosion de cette cohabitation qui
il faut bien le rappeler a été
construite dès son origine sur des
sables mouvants
voilà pour l'actualité au kosovo nous
évoquons cette activité mais aussi
d'actualité politique française en
compagnie de monsieur sarkozy dans
quelques instants
et d'abord la tragédie meurtrière qui
s'est déroulée près de denver au
colorado aux états unis quinze personnes
ont été tuées par deux adolescents dans
un établissement scolaire de la ville de
lyttleton dans le bain dans la banlieue
de denver avant de se suicider les deux
meurtriers ont placé une trentaine de
bombes artisanales dans ce lycée on
cherche on cherchera sans doute encore
longtemps des explications sur les
motivations de cette folie meurtrière
correspondance 2000 guerdat et edward
perrin dans l'église de lyttleton une
fois la nuit tombée ils se sont
retrouvés
à défaut de réponses aux questions
qu'ils se posent par la prière et par le
recueillement il cherche un réconfort le
carnage a commencé à l'heure du déjeuner
deux adolescents vêtus de noir le visage
recouvert d'une cagoule viennent de
pénétrer dans le réfectoire du lycée sur
le parking ils ont déjà battu trois
personnes à l'intérieur
les élèves croit d'abord à une blague de
potache mais ce n'est pas une farce
c'est un jeu de massacre
il faudra près de cinq heures aux unités
spéciales de la police et du fbi y aille
pour évacuer par petits groupes ceux qui
ont encore la force de courir
ils ont tiré sur tout le monde autour de
moi il y avait du sang partout
j'ai supplié celui qui pointait son arme
devant envisage de ne pas me tuer
il a éclaté de rire et a dit que tout ça
et parce que l'an dernier on n'avait pas
été gentil avec moi le dernier bilan de
la fusillade fait état de 15 morts et
d'une vingtaine de blessés certains dans
un état critique le corps criblés de
balles ou des éclats de métal les deux
tueurs se serait suicidé dans la
bibliothèque avant l'assaut des forces
de l'ordre chacun ici les connaissait il
faisait partie d'une petite bande
baptisée la mafia en trench coat eric
harris avait 18 ans dylan klebold old 17
et rick a toujours été un garçon violent
avant nous réconcilions j'avais menacé
de me tuer mais il est et concerne un
type violent l'opération de toute
évidence avait été préparée de longue
date sur le parking et dissimulées un
peu partout dans les couloirs les salles
de classe de l'école les policiers
retrouveront plus de trente bombe
artisanale qu'il faudra désamorcer au
domicile d'eric harris tous les
ingrédients nécessaires à la confection
de ces engins explosifs mais apparemment
aucune lettre aucun message qui
permettraient d'expliquer le geste de
ces deux jeunes hommes
les parents que nous sommes devraient
saisir cette occasion pour se demander
si nous ne pourrions faire davantage
afin de protéger nos enfants des images
d expérience violente il corrons leur
perception des choses à dire ce que les
conséquences de la violence eux l'ont
échappé belle et leurs parents le savent
bien cette vague de violence qui s'est
abattue sur little town n'est pas la
première aux états unis elle n'est que
la plus meurtrière d'une longue série
dominique derda quelles sont les
réactions de l'opinion publique
américaine notamment après les propos du
président clinton
écoutez le drame vous vous en doutez a
largement éclipsé à la une de
l'actualité dans les conversations des
américains les frappes de l'otan sur la
yougoslavie je crois que ce qui résume
le mieux l'état de l'opinion publique et
bien c'est ce que disait la nuit
dernière à la télévision le présentateur
d'une émission spéciale consacrée
justement cette fusillade de lyttleton
il disait comment se fait-il qu après un
mois de guerre aucun de nos soldats
américains ne soit mort en yougoslavie
alors qu il a suffi de quelques heures à
peine pour que nous perdions sur notre
propre sol
autant de nos enfants alors qu'elles
sont aussi les les politiques qui sont
en cause et ce que le problème de la
vente des armées et souligné oui bien
sûr évidemment beaucoup de voix ici
s'élèvent pour réclamer que l'on
contrôle mieux la vente des des armes
individuelles mais pourtant vous savez
tant que les républicains garderont la
majorité au congrès et bien ça restera
un voeu pieux c'est sans doute l'une des
raisons pour laquelle bill clinton
insiste autant qu'il le fait qu'il avait
encore ce soir sur la nécessité pour les
familles américaines pour les
communautés de resserrer les liens qui
les unissent qui les unissent notamment
à leurs enfants pour leur fournir à la
fois des modèles et des guides mais ça
malheureusement eh bien ça ne se décrète
pas à la maison blanche
et ça ne se votent pas au congrès merci
dominique c'est donc pas la première
fois que les états unis ont à connaître
des fusillades dans les écoles les actes
de violences les plus graves commis par
des jeunes se sont passés le plus
souvent dans les états de l'ouest et du
sud américain où l'on entretient une
véritable culture des armes commentaires
olivier galzi
c'était le 24 mars 98 deux enfants de 11
et 13 ans ouvre le feu sur leurs
camarades d'école bilan 5 morts et 11
blessés
un mois plus tard en pennsylvanie lors
d'un bal un adolescent de 14 ans à bâle
un de ses profs avec un revolver
l'amérique est sous le choc et se
réveille sur cette image terrible d'un
tueur qui rit l'image d'un enfant
qu'elle ne reconnaît plus arrogants ou
repentant ils sont pourtant le visage de
l'amérique
keep kinkel a quant à lui ouvert le feu
dans son lycée parce qu'ils en avaient
été exclus blanc classe moyenne on
apprendra lors de son procès que cet
enfant de l'orégon a été élevé une bible
dans la main et un pistolet dans l'autre
comme des dizaines de milliers
d'américains
ceux là ont entre 8 et 10 ans et manie
mieux le pistolet que la batte de
baseball
ils s'entraînent tous les dimanches dans
leur club dans ce genre de club non
seulement on apprend aux enfants à tirer
sur des silhouettes humaines mais en
plus on leur fait des compliments on
leur dit que c'est bien
aux etats unis le droit de porter une
arme est inscrit dans la constitution
c'est le second amendements défendus
pied à pied par la toute puissante
national rifle association
fort de près de 3 millions d'adhérents
ce lobby de l'armement ne veut pas
entendre parler de contrôle des ventes
d'armes et le fait savoir jusqu'au
congrès vit seule dans une maison isolée
cinq jours par semaine dit ce
représentant
elle a le droit d'être armé de se
défendre ne l'oubliez jamais comme le
montre très bien cette vidéo
surveillance les uns attaque les autres
se défendent et c'est ainsi que plus de
200 millions d'armes circulent aux états
unis et tuent chaque année 40 mille
personnes
en france pour les élections européennes
une liste udf seul est probable selon
monsieur hervé de charette
il y aura une autre liste rpr démocratie
libérale avec nicolas sarkozy et alain
madelin en tête avant de nous entretenir
avec monsieur sarkozy voici avec carole
comoé avait pozzo une explication
succincte des programmes respectifs qui
seront proposés par chacune des listes
de droite celle de l'udf et celle du rpr
démocratie libérale l'axé et il ya 3000
ans le congrès approuve la révision
constitutionnelle qui va permettre à la
france de ratifier le traité d'amsterdam
et voilà qu'on croit la droite enfin
réconciliés sur le dossier européen
c'est l'exception de charles pasqua et
de quelques parlementaires
la majorité du groupe herbert rejoint
l'udf et se prononcent pour m c'est que
depuis octobre l'europe n'est plus
taboue au rpr philippe séguin a réuni
ses troupes et doté son nouveau d'un
programme européen compatible avec la
politique menée par le président de la
république
la fidélité à jacques chirac j'ai
d'ailleurs l'argumentaire choisi pour
lancer la campagne européenne
non aux états unis d'europe oui à une
europe unie des états à cette formule
peut être croit devoir répondre europe
quant à nous la formule du président
nous la reprenons intégralement à notre
compte
non aux états unis d'europe oui à
l'europe
iny deux états l'europe fédérale voilà
donc l'expression qui faisaient bondir
le rpr mais qui figure en toutes lettres
dans le programme de l'udf l'udf qui
souhaite notamment l'élaboration d'une
constitution européenne
l'élection d'un président de l'ordre ou
la mise en place d'une défense
européenne
autant de termes sur lesquels le
mouvement néo gaulliste qui aujourd'hui
ne pas être en désaccord et dont
certains se retrouve d'ailleurs dans la
charte rpr des aides mais l udf tient
bon pas question cette fois de plus il
est devant le rpr et encore mois de
transiger sur ses convictions
je veux le dire en votre nom pour que
tout le monde l'entende 1 pour
aujourd'hui et pour demain
qu'on ne compte pas sur nous pour nous
renier une détermination que les
changements à la tête du rpr n'ont pas
entamé différence dans les projets mais
aussi tactique et ambitions personnelles
l'udf entendu aujourd'hui tirer profit
du flou entretenu sur l'europe par le
rpr
le dernier run monsieur sarkozy bon soir
bonsoir monsieur cei alors quelle est la
différence entre vous parce que vous
venez de voir le président la république
aujourd'hui monsieur madelin l'a vu
monsieur bayrou de la vue donc là dessus
vous êtes un peu lié
vous avez géré une même politique
ensemble quelle est la différence entre
jouer j'ai reçu me permettait de 30
secondes d'explication je suis président
du rpr depuis un peu moins d'une semaine
quelle a été ma tâche vous nous avez
montré des images de la situation
internationale
vous avez rappelé que tous nous
soutenons la politique européenne de
jacques chirac
j'ai tendu la main j'ai tout fait pour
obtenir l'union l'union qu'impose à
l'évidence le climat international
qu'elles sont dérisoires ces querelles
lorsqu'on a vu les images que vous nous
avez présenté nous avons participé au
même gouvernement nous avons les mêmes
électeurs et nos électeurs veulent
l'union voilà monsieur sérillon j'ai
tendu la main
j'ai tout tenté plus j'ouvrais la
discussion plus je proposais qu'on se
rend compte qu'on souhaite autour d'une
table qu'on travaille ensemble plus
françois bayrou refusé la main tendue
c'est son droit je ne veux pas
polémiquer il ne voulait pas de l'union
je regrette profondément cette décision
et je comprends ce soir qu'elle doit
être me semble-t-il la déception d'une
grande partie de nos électeurs
mais quelle est votre analyse de cette
position de l'udf pensais que comme l'a
dit un peu durement monsieur millions il
est dit au fond à droite et à plus
d'ambition que de conviction est ce que
c'est aussi votre avis
dans cette affaire voyez vous on a
choisi des prétextes ballon des mois on
a expliqué que c'était la faute à
monsieur séguin comme c'est commode de
trouver un bouc émissaire
je n'ai pas toujours eu les mêmes aux
engagements européens que monsieur
séguin j'ai voté oui à maastricht je
crois profondément à l'europe maintenant
c'est moi et bien moi aussi ça n'allait
pas mais voyez vous je ne veux pas
polémiquer
parce que la polémique est stérile moi
je veux construire l'ensemble du
mouvement gaulliste m'a demandé de
conduire une liste avec quelqu'un dont
je fus proches par l'amitié par les
sentiments par le combat qu'elle
présidente démocratie libéral alain
madelin des grandes voix s'étaient
élevées pour l'union celle du président
de la république celle de valeur
cabestan celle d'edouard balladur
d'alain juppé et tant d'autres mais
maintenant il faut tourner la page
on va rentrer dans la campagne et j'ai
bien l'intention de mener une campagne
avec mes amis notamment à la madelin
dynamique jeune ouverte moderne pour
parler de quoi
mais encore parler de l'europe monsieur
ciné vous avez quelle est la différence
allait faire campagne nicolas sarkozy en
faisant comme s'il n'y avait pas de
liste udf vous voulez pas savoir quel
type de campagne ils vont faire non
monsieur ses rayons je vais faire une
campagne va être simple c'est un
jugement voulait ma place maintenant je
me rends contraire voyez-vous ce que je
vais faire je vais essayer jusqu'au 13
juin de dire très exactement ce que nous
pensons librement franchement sans
précaution excessive
vous me dites quels sont vos différences
l'europe fédérale va donc vous avez dit
c'est dépassé et bien permettez moi
d'expliquer juste en 30 secondes cela
l'ordre fédérales c'est un concept qui a
40 ans d'âge c'est l'europe de grand
papa et vous allez comprendre quand
j'appelle si le concept de françois
bayrou quand même c'est nouveau c'est
quelque chose qui ne défendaient pas
lorsque nous étions gouvernement
ensemble puisque nous avons toujours été
d'accord pour soutenir l'europe qui est
prôné aujourd'hui par jacques chirac
regardez la sphère du kosovo c'est très
intéressant l'europe fédérale ça veut
dire que on décide à la majorité
imaginez un seul pays qui décident
d'envoyer ses hommes se battre risquer
de mourir alors qu'il n'est pas en
accord ce sont des décisions qui doivent
être pris à l'unanimité
c'est un concept cac 40 ans d'âge parce
que c'est un concept qui était adaptée à
l'europe à six par l'europe à 9 pas
l'europe à 15 pas l'europe à 21 demain
pourquoi on nous ressort cette idée de
l'europe fédérale pour une raison très
simple parce qu'il fallait absolument
privilégier des intérêts partisans sur
l'intérêt de l'ensemble de l'opposition
et de la france
c'est ainsi moi je me battrai pour
l'europe des nations parce que je ne
veux pas que la france devienne une
région de l'europe la france et mon pays
c'est ma patrie mais là je crois notre
village est très proche de charles
pasqua
je vais vous indiquez autre chose sur
charles pasqua
c'est aussi assez simple moi j'ai pas
peur de l'europe c'est et votre grand
frère comme un mauvais rhdp à charles
pasqua vous l'avait accompagné vous
l'avons frère turbulent
ainsi les rapports personnels avec lui
vous il va dire si je n'aurais rayons
brûlants il allait bien alors c'est
affectueux mais la chose est simple nous
lyon à l'europe j'ai voté oui à
maastricht j'ai voté oui au traité
d'amsterdam et je pense qu'il n'ya
d'avenir pour la france que si la france
exerce toutes ses responsabilités
pleinement dans le cadre d'europe
je n'ai pas peur de l'europe parce que
je crois dans la france mais je crois
dans l'europe des nations motion
sérillon et voyez vous nous sommes la
seule liste avec un amas de l'ain nous
parlerons à la fois de l'europe qu'il
nous fait pas peur et de la france c'est
toute la politique européenne de jacques
chirac est autre chose qui me séparent
de charles pasqua c'est que notre liste
c'est la seule liste qui pourra dire aux
électeurs qui nous regardent et qui ne
veulent plus de la politique socialiste
c'est la seule liste qui prépare à
l'alternative aux socialistes
charles pasqua veut faire campagne avec
la gauche pour terminer avec philippe de
villiers homme respectable demeurant
mais pas franchement à gauche françois
bayrou et centriste je n'ai entendu la
télévision l'autre jour pour lui une
politique idéal c'est une politique avec
un peu de gauche un peu de sens qu un
peu de droite
moi je pense tout simplement que la
politique sociale et celle est pas bonne
pour la france et donc nous allons
présenter une liste tout à fait
renouveler avec de jeunes candidats
extrêmement féminisé nous allons mener
campagne tous les jours avec beaucoup
d'énergie et croyez moi pour moi une
semaine après la démission de philippe
séguin que j'ai profondément regretté
voir le mouvement gaulliste unie
rassemblée
quitte à se rassembler ce ramdam à
d'autres solutions dont +1 et bien
monsieur sérillon samet d'autres
responsabilités sur mes épaules est ce
que vous croyez que je pense que c'est
facile mais alors qu'est ce que vous
pensez que si c'était facile ça serait
spontanément venus vers moi
mais justement parce que les épreuves
sont là pour être surmontés mais c'est
pour cela que je veux conduire messieurs
balla diouf a exprimé des craintes
récemment en disant ça va peut-être
jouer sur l'électorat qui va se trouver
un peu perturbé peut-être qu'il y aura
un mauvais score écrin mauvais score
vous vous craignez un bon ce qu'un
mauvais scores aussi bon vous savez
l'expérience récente m'a rendu
particulièrement humble vis-à-vis des
électeurs voulaient dire en 97
je pense au repos simplement 95 97
on verra ce qu'on fera les uns les
autres nous avons des choses à dire nous
les gaules y est ce qu'on pourra les
lieux mais roda loire par exemple est ce
qu'on pourra additionner les voix de
françois bayrou d'alain madelin et
nicolas sarkozy de charles pasqua c'est
fait pour lire jacques chirac à une
majorité c'est exactement si je vous
disais est ce que vous quand vous prêts
et le journal de france 2 vous n'avez
comme seule obsession qu'additionner les
spectateurs avec monsieur poivre d'arvor
sur une chaîne concurrente non parce que
moi je suis senti que vous avez vous est
peut-être marque lorsque vous ne croyez
pas que c'est du service public de faire
la politique
vous ne croyez pas que nous nous battons
aussi pour l'intérêt général
vous pensez qu'il ya une différence que
ces moines au jeu le palais masquer la
télévision je ne le pense pas moi je
fais campagne pour porter les idées du
mouvement gaulliste soutenu par jacques
chirac le président de la république ne
s'occupe pas des formations politiques
pensez-vous une minute que s'agissant du
mouvement politique cingoli cerner loin
je vais répondre à votre question est ce
que vous pensez une minute que le
président qui a fondé le mouvement le
mouvement rpr qui est gaulliste qui est
à l'elysée pensez vous qu'il pourrait en
désaccord avec le soutien unanime que
m'apporte le mouvement gaulliste
imaginez vous une minute alors qu'il a
reçu ce matin même alain madelin mon
colistier celui qui animera avec moi
cette liste mais il avait le moi même
navire si françois ouvrard à la minute
monsieur sérillon et vous avez à l'image
formidable avez vous entendu une fois
monsieur chirac défend l'idée d'une
europe fédérale
est ce que vous avez entendu prononcer
ce mot par le président de la république
une seule fois non et vous avez
certainement vu que la seule liste qui
défendra toute la politique européenne
du président de la république c'est la
nôtre je porterai ce message avec alain
madelin
je vais le porter tous les jours dans
tous les coins de france je sais que
c'est difficile c'est justement pour
cela qu'on a besoin de renouveler la
représentation politique donner un
nouveau souffle à l'opposition et
surtout rendre de l'espoir à tous ceux
qui nous regardent
oui cette campagne j'ai l'intention que
ce soit une belle campagne elle est
difficile mais elle sera passionnante
merci monsieur sarkozy mise en relation
directe à partir de 20h50 avec paul amar
gérard leclercq et albert du roy
si charles pasqua qui sera l'invité de
l'émission direct ans côté socialiste
françois hollande qui conduira la liste
parti socialiste radicaux du mouvement
des citoyens étaient aujourd'hui en
campagne et clermont ferrand appelant
lui aussi ses troupes à l'unité
reportage évitant berre et france
veillant en politique comme ailleurs les
mésaventures des uns font souvent les
bonnes affaires des autres
alors bien sûr depuis quatre jours
depuis que fixée
jeter l'épongé depuis que la droite se
cherchent une stratégie pour les
européennes françois hollande que de
liste du ps et d'une partie de la gauche
goûte le spectacle et ne se prive pas
d'ironiser comme si aujourd'hui dans nos
rues les français ceux pour les la tête
dans les moeurs et se poser cette
question y aura-t-il n'y aura-t-il pas
une liste unie de l'opposition et pour
mieux appuyer la démonstration supposé
division d'un côté unités de l'autre
sami naïr numéro 3 de la liste
porte-drapeau du mdc accompagnent
françois hollande dans quasiment tous
ses déplacements
certains proches de jean-pierre
chevènement critiquent ouvertement
l'intervention française en yougoslavie
lui continue d'affirmer qu'il est à
l'aise nous nous en tenons à une
politique de soutien au gouvernement et
à françois hollande pour ce qui concerne
comment dirais-je une solution négociée
nous sommes absolument convaincus que
tout sera fait pour éviter une
intervention terrestre
car en fait d'entreprises en centre de
formation de permanence en salles de
meeting bref à chaque étape du parcours
de campagne le kosovo est le seul
véritable enjeu
il fournit les arguments de campagne il
faut que l'europe se constitue comme
espace politique et espaces de défense
et assure elle même sa propre sécurité
plutôt que de la confier à d'autres et
notamment à l'otan après le changement
de capitaine dans l'équipe opposé
françois hollande a désormais nicolas
sarkozy pour principal concurrent
il espère bien profiter d'une période de
rodage chez l'adversaire adoption
conseil des ministres du nouveau projet
de loi visant à réformer une septième
fois en 15 ans l'audiovisuel madame
catherine trautmann a évoqué les
principales orientations de ce projet
qui comporte notamment une réduction du
temps de publicité sur les chaînes
publiques
explication caroline audrin jean-paul
chaussée catherine trautmann est tout
sourire son projet de loi audiovisuel
malmené à l'automne dernier voit enfin
le jour
il concerne à la fois le secteur public
et le secteur privé pour le public une
holding doit regrouper france 2 france 3
arte la saq et rfo un groupe industriel
de chaînes publiques avec des programmes
complémentaires à sa tête un super
président assisté de directeurs généraux
à la différence de l'actuel président de
france télévisions élus pour trois ans
le super pdg des chaînes pub
il sera nommé par le csa pour cinq ans
côté publicité
elle passera progressivement de 12 à 8
minutes par heure
en contrepartie l'état s'engage à
rembourser l'intégrale d exonération de
la redevance soit au total un milliard
de francs de ressources supplémentaires
cette augmentation du budget des chaînes
publiques devraient permettre le
développement de la création et de la
production
je crois qu'aujourd'hui cette réforme
est une réforme qui convient qui est au
fond qui répond à l'engagement pour le
renforcement du service public mais qui
prend en compte
absolument l'intérêt de touche celui des
téléspectateurs celui des télévisions
des diffuseurs celui des producteurs du
côté du privé les chaînes se voit
contrainte à une plus grande
transparence
le cssa pourra demander aux actionnaires
de chaînes de radios généralistes
davantage d'informations sur des
modifications de capital tout cela afin
de garantir je cite le pluralisme
l'honnêteté et l'indépendance de
l'information
l'obstination de catherine trautmann a
fini par payer
en novembre dernier elle avait dû faire
face à l'hostilité des parlementaires de
la majorité comme de l'opposition
beaucoup craignaient en effet qu'une
réduction de publicité pour les chaînes
publiques ne soit un trop beau cadeau
pour les chaînes privées
ce projet de loi doit passer en première
lecture à l'assemblée le 18 mai et être
appliquée progressivement dans un an
la 7e réforme de l'audiovisuel en 15 ans
vient de voir le jour dans le conflit
qui oppose les personnels des usines du
groupe elf à leur direction il y avait
aujourd'hui une rencontre entre un
médiateur et les représentants de
l'intersyndicale la direction du groupe
prévoit un plan de suppression de plus
de 1300 emplois dans la région de pau la
grève a été reconduite mais les
discussions doivent se poursuivre avec
ce médiateur
et puis à noter que plusieurs préavis de
grève sont lancés notamment à l'aéroport
de nice où la grève continue des
personnels au sol d'air france la
direction régionale d'air france avait
demandé à la justice la libre
circulation de ces avions le tribunal
lui a donné raison
les grévistes protestent contre
l'attribution de certaines tâches dans
la sous traitance ce les autres préavis
de grève sont ils ont été déposés air
france pour demain à roissy et orly par
les personnels au sol et les agents de
piste
a priori ne devrait pas y avoir de
perturbations de trafic selon la
direction d'air france du sport du
football finalement et grâce à laurent
blanc l'olympique de marseille s'est
qualifié pour la finale de coupe
d'europe qui aura lieu le 12 mai
prochain à moscou face aux italiens de
parme mais hier soir à bologne
l'affrontement fut rude et bien au delà
du coup de sifflet final
reportage florent gautreau avec philippe
deslandes on se croirait revenu quelques
années en arrière quand l'om de boli et
deschamps faisait trembler l'europe
aujourd'hui les héros s'appellent porato
blanc et courbis la foulée moins
nombreuses mais la ferveur est la même
ils étaient plusieurs centaines cette
nuit à vouloir approcher ce qui leur
offre une troisième finale de coupe
d'europe en neuf ans
cette qualification après un match
houleux on la doit notamment un jeune
gardien de 24 ans stéphane porato il ne
peut rien faire sur la frappe de parra
mathy à la 18ème minute qui permet à
bologhine d'ouvrir le score mais ses
multiples arrêts seul face aux bolognais
ont permis d'éviter le pire
un deuxième but qui aurait
définitivement éliminé l'om pourra-t-on
a longtemps été la doublure de barthez à
monaco où hier il s'est hissé au niveau
de son modèle avec un sang froid
étonnant est que penser de laurent blanc
dont on hésite à dire qu'il est
exceptionnel tant cela nous paraît
habituel c'est lui qui frappe le penalty
décisif à quatre minutes de la fin
joie de courte durée le penalty est
annulé il faut le retirer
c'était si j'avais un petit peu les
boules excusez moi donc à partir de là
la fait se reconcentrer pour essayer de
marquer une deuxième fois il fallait du
sang froid
il fallait du talent il fallait laurent
blanc courbis lui a eu très peur que l'
arbitre le prive de finale
l'énorme satisfaction que nous avons ce
soir c'est pas ce soir que je
m'arrêterai de pester contre le système
d'arbitrage qui donne un abruti la
responsabilité pendant 90 minutes de
marche d'un résultat d'un match de
football
ironie de l'histoire larbitre en
question a sans doute offert à l'om ce
penalty si important le gardien
bolognais ne semblant pas touché
l'attaquant marseillais l'om arrache une
superbe qualification seulement ternie
par ces images de violence violence sur
la pelouse où ce sommet européen s'est
terminé comme un vulgaire bal du samedi
soir violence dans les tribunes où un
supporter marseillais a été blessé d'un
coup de couteau à la tête
un épilogue lamentable qui contraste
avec la tranquille assurance de l'autre
finaliste
parme avec thuram et boghossian a battu
l'atletico de madrid
parme c'est bologne en plus talentueux
bonne mère prier pour eux un miracle
c'est bien de miracle c'est mieux voilà
nous arrivons à la fin de ce journal je
vous rappelle deux informations que nous
avons développées tout d'abord
concernant le kosovo au bilan d'un
premier mois de guerre une succession de
frappes de l'aviation de l'otan
dernière d'entre elles le siège du parti
socialiste de slobodan milosevic c'était
à belgrade et pour les centaines de
milliers de réfugiés et de personnes
déplacées
la situation humanitaire est toujours
dramatique on a banni on procède d
évacuation d'urgence par hélicoptère
tandis que la tension est très vive au
monténégro entre le pouvoir indépendant
et l'armée serbe quatrième intervention
de monsieur jacques chirac ce soir
c'était à partir de 20 heures monsieur
jacques chirac a rappelé a appelé à
l'intensification des forces des frappes
et à accentuer l'effort humanitaire
demain il sera à washington pour le 50e
anniversaire de l'otan monsieur chirac a
dénoncé de nouveau les massacres les
viols des pillages menés par l'armée où
la police serbe et a dénoncé également
la barbarie du régime serbe
ce que nous vivons vous le savez
c'est l'affrontement entre la barbarie
et la démocratie c'est un vrai combat
pour la paix et pour les droits de
l'homme sur notre continent
c'est le combat de l'honneur nous devons
le mener jusqu'à son terme et nous
devons le gagner
dans l'actualité également la travers la
tragédie meurtrière au colorado près de
denver aux états unis deux adolescents
ont tué 15 personnes dans un lycée dans
quelques secondes la météo vous sera
présentée par isabelle martinet à 21h10
la route allant vers un très beau
téléfilm avec le millas miquel et
sylvain joubert à 22h55 ça se discute et
jean luc delarue à une heure du matin le
journal de la nuit vous sera présentée
par laurence ostolaza et puis à 1h25
attention c'est la 1000e émission du
cercle entouré de tous ceux qui ont
animé le magazine avant lui notamment
bernard à michel field
philippe lefait vous fera revivre les
meilleurs moments du cercle depuis 1992
demain à 13h retrouvez rachid arhab à
demain 20h bonsoir merci
je